The only problem with Microsoft is they just have no taste.
They have absolutely no taste and what that means is that I don't mean that in a small way.
I mean that in a big way.
In the sense that...
...they don't think of original ideas and they don't bring much culture into their product.
And, you say "Why is that important?"
Well, you know, proportionally spaced fonts come from typesetting and beautiful books.
That's where one gets the idea.
If it weren't for the Mac, they would never have that in their products.
And so, I guess, I am saddened not by Microsoft's success.
I have no problem with their success.
They've earned their success for the most part.
I have a problem with the fact that they just make really third-rate products.